Philippe boncarer rapporteur de la
commission des lois vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre maises chers collègues après
avoir rappelé les propos du président à
l'arché sur l'immigration la situation
n'est plus tenable vous avoir dit que le
travail technique entre les rapporteurs
s'était très bien déroulé que la
majorité sénatoriale et d'accord sur la
quasi totalité des sujets et vous avoir
dit qu'il existe et vous avoir dit qu'il
existe des solutions pour réécrire
l'article 3 je voudrais organiser mon
propos introductif sur quatre points
premièrement nous avons une obligation
de résultat deuxièmement l'engagement de
fermeté respecté troisièmement nous vous
proposons un retour du Parlement dans la
définition de la politique migratoire et
quatrièmement nous nous inscrivons dans
le cadre conventionnel et
constitutionnel le tout au service de
l'action publique premièrement une
obligation de résultat qu'est-ce que je
veux dire par là et bien le Sénat doit
adopter un texte personne ne
comprendrait qu'il ne soit pas en mesure
de répondre à l'attente de nos
concitoyens et vous savez aussi que le
refus du temps dit programmé à
l'Assemblée nationale peut laisser
planer un doute sur la capacité de
celle-ci d'aller au bout des débats et
donc personne ne comprendrait que les
deux assemblées ne soient pas en mesure
d'élaborer un texte c'est une question
de légitimité parlementaire et tout
particulièrement pour le Sénat vous le
savez tous nous estimons que le Sénat
est aujourd'hui le point d'équilibre
institutionnel il nous appartient d'être
cohérent avec nous-mêmes et de le mettre
en œuvre dans ce texte vous dire
également que deuxièmement ce texte
introduit des éléments indiscutables de
de fermeté vous en aurez de nombreux
témoignages c'était déjà l'objet du
texte présenté par Monsieur le Ministre
de l'Intérieur qui vient de s'enexliquer
vous avez eu une première étape avec la
commission des lois du mois de mars et à
l'occasion de la séance une deuxième
étape nous permet ett d'adopter de
nouveaux amendements c'est bien un
nouveau paysage de la politique
migratoire du pays qui se dessine et non
une addition de mesur vous dire aussi
troisièmement que il y a me semble-t-il
dans ce texte en tout cas dans
l'évolution que nous avons voulu lui
donner un retour du Parlement à quoi je
fais référence je fais référence au fait
que la politique migratoire n'est pas
simplement une politique diplomatique
pas plus qu'une politique mémorielle
elle est régalienne elle s'écrit au
présent et elle s'écrit au présent sous
le contrôle du Parlement dans le débat
annuel que nous vous proposons l'article
1a du texte à travers les nombreuses
données attendues bien nous souhaitons
vous donner nous donner collectivement
les moyens d'être beaucoup plus précis
sur les évaluations de notre politique
mais
et surtout d'en fixer les objectifs
c'est bien ça l'idée de l'article 1a
c'est que le Parlement puisse redonner
un cap sur la définition de la politique
migratoire et 4è et dernier élément vous
dire que nous avons essayé d'inscrire
notre action en tout cas l'analyse que
vos rapporteurs ont fait des amendements
dans le respect de nos engagements
conventionnels et de notre Constitution
alors j'entends très bien le débat dans
la société entre liberté individuelle et
droit collectif mais je ne crois pas je
ne crois pas que l'État de droit entrave
l'action publique la CEDH admet une
marge d'appréciation nationale et si
l'on veut bien regarder avec précision
les décisions du Conseil constitutionnel
celui-ci n'a jamais interdit au pouvoir
exécutif ou à l'exécutif ou au
législatif de mettre en œuvre ses
politiques
avec ces différents éléments je voulais
finalement peut-être anticiper sur la
suite du débat et vous dire qu'il
faudrait faire attention à ne pas
introduire des données
inconstitutionnelles qui n'apportent
rien à la crédibilité du Parlement et
surtout qui se retend ensuite à une
censure laisserait entendre à nos
concitoyens qu'en fait l'action publique
ne serait pas possible et c'est par cela
que je terminerai en vous disant que je
crois très profondément que la politique
migratoire qui vous est proposée
peut-être efficace elle ne sera jamais
efficace à 100 % et je partage le
sentiment d'humilité qui vous até
exprimé en préambule par le ministre de
l'intérieur mais c'est indiscutablement
avec ce texte une politique qui sera
plus efficace et aussi avec les
amendements que vous apporterez merci à
tous et à toutes de votre
attention